[Music]
spare well are the largest predator that
ever existed on earth larger of a larger
dinosaur our goal is to interact with
[Music]
Fabrice Nellore is an engineer biologist
and founder of the Darwin project his
goal is to record and analyze sperm
whale vocalizations Darwin project it
res equation do of his animals
communicate like us so the idea is to
see if there's information insult
sperm whales communicate using a series
of complex clicking some clicks are
short as a thousandth of a second when
we get intimate salt we save adverse
battle is not random maybe it's not
impossible but these animals have a very
sophisticated language
Fabrice is objective is to gather as
many recordings of the whales as
possible to figure out if that language
exists but sperm whales are not the
easiest animals to get close to maybe
only ten years ago the world was going
into the water whisper well because they
are predator if you both a verb if you
eat remove a boat or should try to kill
one of them they can be extremely
dangerous by free diving diving on a
single breath of air Fabrice is able to
get incredibly close to the whales they
usually don't come to the divers that's
why we free dive and we try to get these
very exceptional observations it's
through these intimate interactions that
Fabrice is able to capture the
recordings he needs to one day unlock
the secret of their communication with a
sperm whale when they decide to come to
see you you are the subject they are
looking at you they are analyzing you
and this is really something I'd never
seen with a variable for me it varies an
animal but as a chance to open the
little Bridget with animals and even it
is a spare one